[Music]
in 1988 Aerospace designer Brad Sorensen
went to Norton Air Force base for the
annual air show the show was the chance
for aerospace companies and Military
contractors to show off new technology
to top military and government officials
Brad wanted to network and maybe grab a
new client or two at some point Brad got
turned around and separated from his
group he hopped into another group and
ended up in a large Hangar watching a
presentation given by a three-star
General at first it was the typical
rundown for various top secret aircraft
Brad figured he was in the right place
he wasn't the general signaled to
someone on a huge curtain was pulled
revealing three aircraft that nobody was
expecting
foreign
fellow Aerospace designer Mark
mccandlish called Brad to see how the
air show was Brad was silent for a long
time Mark asked him what was wrong Brad
sounded scared and depressed he said I
think I saw something I wasn't supposed
to see Mark was confused they both had
top secret clearance they worked for
General Dynamics Lockheed Martin
Northrop McDonald Douglas Boeing
Rockwell International they worked for
Usual Suspects right as Aerospace
designers and illustrators they often
learned about experimental aircraft
before they were even built so what
could be more secret than that Brad said
after the presentation they pulled a
curtain back to reveal three flying
saucers completely silent and hovering a
few feet above the ground
Mark asked Brad to describe them he said
they look like something out of the
1950s they had a flat bottom sloped
sides and a dome on top and on the Dome
were small bubbles that look like they
contained cameras the smallest saucer
was about 24 feet in diameter the next
one was about 60 feet and the largest
saucer was about 120 feet wide the
general giving the presentation called
them arvs or alien reproduction Vehicles
the nickname they gave the saucers was
flux Liners in electromagnetism electric
flux is the measurement of an electric
field through a given surface so this
was a bit of a hint next to the small
saucer was a television playing various
test flights video showed a saucer or an
arv hovering silently over a dry lake
bed somewhere in the desert then the arv
did Maneuvers that seemed like bouncing
and then finally the saucer stopped and
flew straight up as fast as a bullet the
audience was stunned nobody had ever
seen anything fly like this Mark asked
Brad if they explained how an aircraft
could move in such a way Brad said he
was surprised at how simple the
mechanics were Mark said wait what you
got to see inside of the Flying Saucer
Brad said that next to the craft was a
large easel which described the internal
components plus the smallest saucer had
some of its side panels removed so
visitors could see the complete interior
Brad Sorensen saw the engine the life
support system the crew area complete
with jump seats and steering mechanisms
Mark mccandlish was blown away and Mark
being a designer and illustrator asked
Brad if he could remember specifics
about the saucer Mark wanted to draw a
diagram Brad said he could remember and
would tell Mark everything but there was
no way he was doing that over the phone
thank you
[Music]
Brad Sorensen and Mark mccandlish met
for lunch the next day to talk about the
alien reproduction vehicles that Mark
had seen at the air show Mark wanted to
try and sketch a diagram of what Brad
saw both men worked in Aerospace as
designers and illustrators so they were
familiar with a lot of the technology
and were trained to pay attention to
detail the first thing Brad noticed is
that the arv seemed kind of worn they
had chips in their paint fingerprints
and smudges all over them clearly the
American Military had this technology
for a long time Brad went on to sketch
out and describe the interior of the arv
the Dome at the top is actually half a
sphere the crew jump seats are in the
top of the sphere the flat bottom of the
saucer is a large capacitor array over a
foot thick on top of the array are
oxygen tanks for the crew to breathe and
to maintain air pressure within the
craft then Brad revealed two bombs
dropped by the three star at the airshow
one the saucer can travel faster than
light lily what and two it uses Zero
Point Energy wait what well Zero Point
Energy would require its own episode to
really get into it but here's the gist
zero point is the lowest possible energy
that a quantum mechanical system can
have
actually did you just yawn well that
explanation did not help well in
classical mechanics empty space is just
empty space but in quantum mechanics no
space is truly empty there are
fluctuating fields in constant motion
and there are particles that act like
waves that wink in and out of existence
these fields and particles require
energy to do that energy that exists
everywhere even in the vacuum of space
for example liquid helium at absolute
zero in a vacuum is still liquid you
can't have liquid unless the atoms are
in motion helium doesn't freeze because
Zero Point Energy keeps the atoms moving
well yeah but how much energy could it
actually be in in nothing Well physicist
John Wheeler and Richard Feynman
calculated that Zero Point Energy in the
vacuum of space is so powerful that the
amount of space that fits in a coffee
cup has enough energy to boil and
evaporate all the oceans on earth a
coffee cup well if Zero Point Energy
boils away the oceans we can refill them
with the tears of oil company Executives
and the politicians in their pockets
you're catching on it was at this point
where Mark mccandlish put his Aerospace
design skills to work he converted
Brad's rough sketch to a technical
blueprint to scale of a functioning
Flying Saucer over the next couple of
years mark would perfect his drawing
after speaking with other eyewitnesses
who gave him more and more details will
it wait more people saw this Flying
Saucer than just the one guy oh yeah
many more people
[Music]
foreign
speaking with Brad Sorensen and studying
his drawing Mark McCandless became
fascinated with the arv project and
started doing his own research as
interesting as this was it was still
just a report from a single eyewitness
but the more Mark looked into the secret
project the more people he would find
that saw the arv worked on it and even
flew it in the early 1990s Mark ran into
Kent selin at an air show a lot of
action at these issues huh there is you
want to check one out nah I'm good Kent
was a crew chief working at Edwards Air
Force Base and one day he was sent out
to repair a piece of equipment and on
his way to the job site he passed a
hangar with the doors slightly open he
looked inside and saw a flying saucer
just hovering there silently now without
any prompting Kent described the arv
exactly how Brad did flat bottom domed
roof with smaller domes that held
cameras and just as the initial shock
was wearing off Kent had a gun in his
face a voice told him to shut his eyes
and get down on the ground a bag was
thrown over in head and he was dragged
to an interrogation room for an 18-hour
debrief verbal colonoscopy exactly the
aggressive military reaction didn't
surprise Mark what surprised him was
this happened in 1973 almost 20 years
earlier so how long has the military
been sitting on this thing what happened
what had a dome on the top with these
little glass things on top looked like
there was a camera under each one and I
said really yeah no you know no landing
gears it was hovering I said let me
borrow your pen so I took out
a Kodak lens cleaning tissue package
that I had in my camera bag was the only
thing I could think of to draw and I
just I did a quick sketch of the sailing
reproduction vehicle as described by my
friend Brad Sorensen back in 1988 and I
said is that what you saw he says oh
you've seen one
I wasn't
sure until this moment that the story
was absolutely true so that was when I
knew there was a second point of
confirmation in addition to Kent selling
there is at least one other person from
the military who's been willing to go on
record about the arv
that there was one facility at Norton
Air Force Base that was close hold not
even the wing Commander there could know
what was going on
and during that time period uh
throughout my career it was always
rumored by the pilots that uh that was a
cover for in fact a location of one UFO
craft
and the reason for that location was uh
folks that could come out land at Norton
play golf be part of a golf tournament
so forth and during that process could
go by the facility and actually see the
UFO
yeah hold on so they would fly into a
secret Air Base go see a UFO and then uh
play golf that's what the colonel said
that's a very military industrial
complex Bilderberg skeleton bones
Bohemian growth thing you do it really
is throw in some ritual sacrifice and it
would be perfect all right let's keep it
nice hey I'm just spilling the tea the
more Mark McCandless asked around the
more people he found who knew about the
arv Flying Saucer project the story
really started to come together when
Mark was introduced to Lieutenant
Colonel Wendell Stevens Colonel Stevens
was a pilot who chased UFOs in the
Arctic many years ago Mark asked the
colonel hey any chance you took
photographs of something that looks like
the craft i'm describing oh please tell
me there are pictures of this thing
there are pictures
[Music]
foreign
were taken in 1967 so it would seem that
the design changed slightly over the
years the only major difference between
the 1967 arv and the one Brad saw in
1988 was that the bubbles on top were
larger in the older craft Mark figured
this was because cameras got smaller
over the years cameras are now so small
that we can assume that the current arv
models have even smaller or no bubbles
at all Mark McCandless noted that even
though there's a large variation in the
shapes of the UFOs that have been
photographed over the years the general
design is the same round with a flat
bottom angled edges and an upper
compartment some UFO photos go back to
1950 so these vehicles have been around
for at least 75 years but they may have
been here longer than that a lot longer
an ancient Hindu and Sanskrit texts
there are many stories about vimanas the
flying Machines of the Gods the
Mahabharata written about 3000 years ago
describes events that happened as far
back as 5000 BC and vamanas are
mentioned quite a bit they can fly at
Great speeds fly into space and even fly
underwater but what's really interesting
about the vamanas in the ancient text is
the engines are described in detail
s must be made the body of the famana
like a large flying bird of night
material inside one should play some
Mercury Engine with its iron heating
device below through related force in
Mercury which triggers the buoyancy
swerve a man sitting inside can travel
great distances in the sky the
Vallarta's movements are such that it
can climb vertically they send
vertically move forward and backward
with the help with machines humans can
fly in the air and Celestial beings can
come to Earth in other passages and
texts vamanas are described as having a
Mercury Vortex engine that's pretty
specific so a couple of questions if
Mercury is in a cylinder and is then
heated will it circulate and cause of
vortex
yes it will but what if the vamanas
weren't using heat what if they were
using electricity like the arv does will
Mercury circulate if a current is
applied to it it sure will this
technology was very interesting to
Germany in the 1930s you might be
familiar with the glacca or the Bell the
glacca was about 12 feet high and nine
feet in diameter it used two high-speed
counter rotating cylinders filled with
Solutions of liquid mercury the rotating
Mercury supposedly allowed the Bell to
defy gravity we know that if you apply
current to Mercury it will rotate
reverse the polarity of the current it
rotates in the opposite direction at
this point in Mark's research he was
convinced the arv project was real and
he began to unravel the mystery of its
method of propulsion in order to
completely solve that piece of the
puzzle mark would need to speak to
people who claimed to have been inside a
UFO so he started talking to abductees
foreign
spoke to several UFO abductees most of
them remembered the aliens and the
experiments they endured but none of
them remembered seeing the engine except
one she said the craft she was on was
round and in the center was a column
full of silver liquid rotating very
rapidly and there was a wheel or device
on the column that was rotating in the
opposite direction people who have found
UFO crashes like the Roswell crash have
reported seeing similar technology in
the wreckage and there were dozens of
patents for anti-gravity devices and
vehicles that use electricity to fly
great distances at Great speeds
unsurprisingly most of these patents
appeared after Roswell in 1947 but a lot
of the patterns are built on the work of
Nikola Tesla mommy between the many
eyewitness accounts for military
contractors and the accounts of alien
abductees mark was able to discern how
the arv operates the circular base was
essentially a huge Tesla coil multiple
metallic layers stacked on each other
with a slight Gap in between at acting
as a capacitor to store and redirect
electricity because the craft uses a lot
of electricity possibly a million volts
or more it generates a powerful
electromagnetic field by manipulating
this field the arv pilot can generate
thrust the center column contains two
counter rotating cylinders of liquid
mercury the upper platform acts as an
additional capacitor working with the
lower capacitor to allow the craft to
move in any direction the control system
that the pilot uses is simple with his
right hand the pilot has a lever which
controls how much electricity is
deployed from the capacitors at the
Pilot's left hand is what looks like a
large trackball this control sends power
in any direction 360 Degrees oxygen
tanks and the life support system is
attached to the lower platform the arv
has no windows it uses what's called a
synthetic Vision system the cameras on
the exterior of the vehicle allow the
pilot to see these cameras work in
conjunction with each other and send
separate feeds to the Pilot's left and
right eyes so he can see in three
dimensions like how a VR headset works
that's the entire thing in a nutshell
there's not much to it aren't you
forgetting one thing what how the hell
do these things go faster than the speed
of light ah right that's where it gets
really fun
[Music]
the arv is a vehicle that captures
generates stores and redirects a
tremendous amount of energy in a field
around the craft this field is
manipulated by the pilot which allows it
to fly in any direction but that doesn't
explain how the arv can exceed the speed
of light or does it a number of papers
have been released by physicists within
the last 20 or 30 years that explain how
a craft like this could travel beyond
the speed of light the reason nothing
can go faster than light is because as
you go faster your mass increases the
closer you get to light speed the closer
your mass gets to Infinity oh that's a
lot of myths it is it's way too much
Zero Point Energy is everywhere and is
responsible for the effects of gravity
inertia and mass so a vehicle that
utilizes Zero Point Energy drawing it in
from its environment could theoretically
reduce gravity and lower its mass and
the faster the arv goes the more energy
it absorbs the lower its mass gets this
is like the opposite of E equals MC
squared but the math shows that this
process doesn't actually violate the
laws of physics in September 2000
physicist Miguel alcubieri released a
paper called the warp drive he describes
how a vehicle could go faster than light
without violating relativity what the
vehicle does is compress press
space-time directly ahead of it and
expand space-time directly behind it
that would allow the arv to go extreme
distances very quickly like to the edge
of the solar system in a few minutes
alcubieri's paper also describes how the
vehicle at the center of this warp field
would not experience any change in
gravity at all no matter how fast you
accelerate or how sharply you turn the
bubble around you maintains the exact
conditions you had when you started
traveling this would explain why UFOs
can maneuver so dramatically an aircraft
moving at seven thousand miles per hour
doing a sharp right turn would turn the
human body into chunky salsa seat belts
would matter your organs would be
crushed by the g-forces though you would
stroke out before that happened but
using alcubiri's warp drive you don't
feel any of it you could literally
accelerate at a hundred G forces and not
spill your Martini food is martinis on
this flight I figure if I'm traveling to
another solar system I like to be
relaxed in a little buzz oh how did the
stewardesses look
uh they're called flight attendants now
Pilots have reported that UFOs moving at
extreme speeds do so without generating
any noise or any exhaust of any kind
UFOs have been said to generate energy
out of thin air
well that's because they do
what is Zero Point Energy I'm going to
show you a different many different
definitions but let me quote Nikola
Tesla quote throughout space there is
energy
is this energy static or kinetic
if static our hopes are in vain
if kinetic and we know for certain it is
then it is a mere question of time when
men will succeed in attaching their
Machinery to the very real work of
nature
many generations may pass but in time
our Machinery will be driven by a power
obtainable at any point in the universe
and so there ladies and gentlemen is the
basic birth of the concept of zero point
energy
the reason it's called alien
reproduction vehicle is that it's based
on the study of extraterrestrial
vehicles but it is manufactured by human
uh Military Intelligence Aerospace
Contracting Arrangements uh and this is
very important it means that we Homo
sapiens have the ability to access this
so-called zero point field of energy
which the is the ambient field of energy
from which all matter and energy is
fluxing and can access that energy and
generate all the power we need to run
this planet without fossil fuels or
pollution
foreign
most of the information in today's
episode comes from a documentary created
by filmmaker James Allen It's called
zero point the story of Mark mccandlish
and the flux liner if you're interested
in this topic and how could you not be
I'll link to the full doc below it's 90
minutes of jaw-dropping stories
but Damon
damn it we're gonna get by
would you really no but how much of the
story is true well even though we have
eyewitness testimony of the arv aka the
flux liner AKA The Flying Saucer it's
still just testimony we don't have
physical evidence we have pitches we do
have pictures of saucers that's true we
know that most are hoaxes but there are
a few that haven't been explained as to
the science behind Zero Point Energy
there's not a consensus it's a
relatively new field of study relatively
nice some physicists believe Zero Point
Energy is real the math works but some
physicists are more skeptical and can
still get the math to work without zero
point even if Zero Point Energy is real
and I believe it is Mark didn't really
know how the arv captured the energy
maybe it can be absorbed through the
vehicle's magnetic field we don't know
Louis sure would be nice to have the
Tesla files that would definitely stolen
by the FBA yeah it would be nice to have
that stuff now as for the Mercury Vortex
drive people have known about this
technology for a long time and really
same with Zero Point Energy we've known
about that since Tesla maybe before but
nobody has been able to get either
technology to work
excuse me if anyone got free energy to
work they would be disappeared faster
than you can say Exxon Mobil yeah it
would seem that whoever comes close to
getting free energy to work they
suddenly come down with a case of severe
bad luck I've seen copies of
inter-office
Correspondence among defense contractors
that openly stated that they felt the
technology was a fundamental enabling
technology that it it had
all kinds of different defense
applications but it also had a lot of
serious civilian applications it would
be beneficial to humanity as a whole to
the environment it seems obvious that
someone perhaps a group may be some kind
of a rogue civilization within our
society has captured the technology
they're exploiting it for their own aims
for their own interests whatever those
might be there's not a sliver of doubt
in my mind that it exists
foreign
basically is that there's a lot of work
going on in the Aerospace industry
that
would indicate that we have black
projects that have gone even darker
Stefan marinov was the leader of the
European free energy movement in 1997 he
made tremendous strides in the
technology before he could develop his
first prototype ethyl out of a window Dr
John Mullen a nuclear physicist used to
work for McDonald Douglas one of the
largest military contractors in the
world he died of arsenic poisoning in
2004 his girlfriend was originally a
suspect but she was found dead in her
apartment shortly after there are no
more suspects there is no investigation
there will be no trial Dimitri petrinov
invented a plasma battery that powered
his home for 14 months in 2010 he went
to a bakery and was never seen again
Zachary Warfield was another inventor
who developed his own plasma battery
Warfield visited petrinov to exchange
information that same year Warfield died
in a strange boating accident in
Washington DC Eugene malov was a
physicist and expert in cold fusion he
claimed he had a working prototype of a
free energy device in 2004 the day
before he was to make a public
announcement about his findings he was
beaten to death already goes actually
patented free energy Technology based on
the zero point field in 2007 he was
about to get on a flight to meet
investors who were going to fund his
research he was found dead in his car at
the airport Rory Johnson created a cold
fusion laser activated magnetic motor
that generated over 500 horsepower he
planned a public demonstration of four
vehicles equipped with his magnetron
motor the U.S department of energy
placed a restraining order on this
technology preventing publication and
though in excellent Health he died
unexpectedly soon after Mark tomian a
physicist patented technology called a
Star Drive which uses Zero Point Energy
very similar to the arv in 2009 he
developed a working prototype shortly
after he died from an unexpected cardiac
event his research is missing Stan Myers
developed a working end engine that ran
on water in 1997 he died from what was
officially reported as a cerebral
hemorrhage this happened while having
lunch with two potential investors his
last words were I was poisoned I
remember I said that most of this
episode comes from a documentary created
by James Allen he ruffled a lot of
feathers doing his research specifically
at Lockheed Martin
and so I you know I'm kind of mystified
is why a lot of more people a lot more
people haven't picked up on this and
like really and sort of like hammered on
Lockheed or Grumman or whoever to say
are you guys really doing this I
actually called a you know a spokesman
at uh at Lockheed and asked her straight
up
um I'm like so what's going on with your
electric invitics program and she's like
well we're not at Liberty to discuss
those programs and I'm like really why
not she's like well it might threaten
our competitive advantage and I really
wish I'd gotten that on film or tape
because uh my next documentary Tom are
you listening I want to do a uh sort of
a uh
investigative documentary on antique
specifically on anti-gravity
um in the Aerospace
industry oh I can't wait to see that new
documentary this kid is a hero was a
hero oh you gotta be kidding me
while still editing the film before it
was even released James Allen was
diagnosed with an aggressive form of
cancer he was dead in three months I'm
so angry right now that interview clip I
showed was from six weeks before his
cancer diagnosis did he look sick to you
no he did not autopsy results revealed
an unbelievably aggressive tumor that
usually occurs in patients with cancer
for years not weeks and his blood
contained 12 heavy metals and
radioisotopes at toxic levels manganese
beryllium thorium and uranium were found
in his blood James Allen never got to
see his documentary released and his
next film which would expose
anti-gravity technology being pursued by
military contractors now that would
never happen this is a bunch of
these governments
companies doing
what are we gonna stand up something
about these
yeah I know even Mark mccandlish was
afraid you've actually heard a couple
different stories about people being
shot down when they're trying to try and
implement this stuff you are killed or
killed yeah I mean there's there's many
times I will anyway good night with my
nine millimeter under my pillow Reloaded
and I wonder why they haven't killed me
you know I honestly did
well at least he made it right
tell me he made it did he make it well
oh no this past April Mark was found
dead in his apartment let me guess he
took his own life yep you better watch
your back sport I do I honestly believe
the only thing keeping me safe is all of
you I just
hope that's enough
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's Heckle
fish this has been the y-files if you
had fun or learned anything do me a
favor and like subscribe comment share
that stuff really helps and like most
topics we cover on the channel today's
topic was recommended by you although
you warned me to be careful with this
one if there's a story you'd like to see
or learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips but please keep my personal safety
in mind and special thanks to our
patrons who make this channel possible I
couldn't do this without you definitely
thank you right near you thank you
patrons thank you thank you thank you so
much patrons and look if you'd like to
support the channel consider becoming a
member on patreon buy something from the
Heckle fish store uh that's the y-file
store well Pop Quiz what sells more
t-shirts with the logo on it or t-shirts
with my face on it well I don't think
that's really
it's the Wi-Fi store whatever you got to
tell yourself to get through today Chief
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
and if I don't put out a video next week
come looking for me
[Music]